TV legend Adam West has died he was 88  the actors family confirmed the news  Adam died on Friday in Los Angeles after  a short battle with leukemia tweeting  our beloved aww passed away he was the  greatest we'll miss him like crazy we  know you'll miss him too  Adam was best known for his role of  Bruce Wayne in the 1960's television  series of Batman you saw it yourself  Robin and most recently for his  hilarious role as the mayor of Quahog on  Family Guy  my name isn't Adam wee or is it  celebrities quickly took to social media  to share their condolences slash tweeted  he was quote really saddened to hear of  Adams passing Antonio sabato jr. called  him a class act and one of the nicest  people ever  Adams co-star and former cat woman Julie  Newmar tells et quote he was wonderful  spot-on  with a twinkle in his eye  you